Okay, oh my god, I'm very sorry.
This took so long.
I just realized our BGM stopped.
I don't have a BGM, everybody.
I forgot one thing.
Everything.
This, okay, I need to tell you guys.
I'm very sorry for all of you.
Thank you for staying up.
I'm so sorry.
There's a lot of technical difficulties, but thank you so much for staying up.
I really appreciate it, and I'm very sorry if you're like, Please, Doki, I fucking waited for so long.
Thank you, everybody, for waiting.
I don't have a BGM right now.
I mean, technically, you know what?
Let's grab something.
Maybe I can grab something real quick.
Give me a sec.
Maybe I can find something for us.
Oh my gosh, just so you guys know, I am a mess right now.
Everything that could sort of go wrong, sort of went wrong.
Everything went wrong throughout the planning of this entire thing.
So, that's why, like, you know, I've just been, like, going, doing, there's been so much stuff.
There's honestly, like, maybe this music.
I don't know what this sounds like.
Maybe this would fit.
Let's see, where is it?
Oh, I'm sorry if this was really loud.
I'm really sorry.
I can't even hear it.
What is this?
Media Source 7?
Okay, this works.
This...
This works.
Yes, alright.
You know what?
This works.
Hello, everybody.
So, if you guys didn't know, I've been organizing this ApeDokiBird X Oversight Apex Custom.
And it has been, we've gone through a lot for this.
There's, we had, like, we had an issue the day before where we were missing one JP pro player.
Because we found out on, actually, no, two.
We found out on the, like, we were missing a JP pro player.
Because their manager got back and was like, sorry, our schedules just don't align.
But we found out the day before.
So we were scrambling to get a replacement.
Because we put all in on those pro players.
Because Tempo was like, don't worry, they'll say yes.
They didn't say yes.
So we were like, fuck, okay, we can find one more.
So, not only that, but I also had to find replacements for other players, too.
So, like, at one point, we had two teams that wanted to merge together.
Because, from the forum.
So, this whole custom, there's gonna be people I've personally invited.
People that asked me for an invitation.
And people that applied via the forum.
Unlucky for me, there were some people who applied from the forum that I invited via the forum.
And they wanted to merge teams together because they couldn't get another plus one.
So I was like, yeah, sure.
But then I had to do, because of the merging of the teams, it was like super last minute.
And then I had to, in 24 hours, find an entire team replacement.
And I'm like, ah!
So I was like, ah!
It would've been 24 hours, because, you know, today I had to announce it.
So, yeah, so, luckily, an entire team is just two players.
Because Temple got me on the pro player.
Sorry, okay, I'll turn it down.
Temple got me in the pro player.
You know how?
Because I asked, okay, by the way, I was like, Temple, how the fuck do you, this is the hardest thing I've ever organized.
I've organized so many events, but this right here has to be anything that could go wrong has went wrong.
And this is 60 players.
To be fair, this is the most amount of players in an event that I've hosted.
So, like, I had to coordinate with 60 fucking players.
By the, me and Temple.
Temple got the pro players down.
He was like, he's got that shit down.
I had to deal with the others.
I had to find the others.
So, like, at one point, like, I would invite people.
Like, not invite, but like, some people have captains.
We'll have a captain slot, because I was like, you go find the other player.
And they'll come back to me and be like, I don't know who to get.
And I'll be like, okay, you play with this person.
You're going to play with this person.
I would message, like, six plus people.
Like, one of them, literally, I had an emergency replacement that I had to find.
I had to find an emergency replacement three hours ago.
Three hours ago, I got an emergency replacement.
Because they were like, we couldn't get a plus.
We couldn't find a plus one.
So, I was like, I messaged, like, six plus people.
And I was like, by the way, I'm messaging a lot of people.
So, like, whoever responds first, you're in.
You're in.
You're fucking in.
By the way, because of all of this that's going on, I have emergency backup subs now.
Just in case.
I was like, I'm sorry, we finally filled the slot.
But, like, don't worry.
If anybody drops out on the 30th, are you okay to be an emergency backup?
And they're like, yeah, we can.
So, I was like, oh, thank God.
And then I asked Tempo.
I asked Tempo.
I was like, how the fuck do you do this every day?
I was like, how the fuck do you fucking coordinate with 60 people every fucking day of your life?
And he was like, I'm just used to it.
He was like, you don't understand, Doki.
As being in charge of oversight, if any pro player pisses me off, they will get blacklisted.
And I, and oversight, is in charge of majority of the tournaments in NA.
So...
So, he was like, so...
So, because of that, they do not want to piss him off.
I do not have that power, sadly.
He was also like, he was like telling me, he was telling me, he was like, oh, yeah.
I also dealt with kids before, because he used to be a teacher.
So, to him, Apex players are like children to him.
So, he's like, he was a teacher before.
So, he knows how to handle children.
I don't.
So, he's like, if anything...
He's dealt with worse and everything.
So, he's just like, you get used to it.
And I'm like, I don't know, I don't know if I can.
This was honestly the most, one of the most frustrating things I've ever planned.
Like coordinating with 60 people, it has to be...
By the way, I need you guys to know, it's me and Tempo.
Doing all of this.
I don't have management helping me out with this, because...
I like organizing events myself, because I like full control on things.
Because it's the only way I can feel control.
But, oh my gosh, that was a little bit of a mistake.
Oh my god.
The roadblocks I had to go through to get all of this put together.
Like, everything together and everything.
I'm a very big professionist either, so...
Everything sort of came down, like, last minute.
And everything, and...
I'm just glad we're here now.
I'm so glad we're here now.
Oh my god, I wish I could like...
Like, I'm just like re-reading my messages.
I'm re-reading my messages to Tempo.
And I'm just like, how do you do it?
It's just me screaming into the void.
And the void is...
The void is literally Tempo.
Because the last two weeks was just me fucking screaming.
Oh my god.
Anyway.
Let us...
Let us give you guys, if you guys don't know the time.
Here is the time for the entire event.
I'm sorry, I know the BGM is a little bit weird.
Because it's like...
I was desperate to... I don't have a BGM.
That was like the one thing I forgot to do.
So, if you guys didn't see the time.
You guys are not gonna hear me too.
It's gonna be silent, by the way.
Actually...
No, I can put...
I can like, put the picture.
Sorry, I'm like coughing too.
My... Everything's going...
Everything.
So...
Wow!
I was gonna swap it.
But then I was like...
Ah, fuck it.
Yeah!
November 30th!
Which is December 1st in Japan.
6pm PST.
11am JST.
Ooh, logo!
Why you look at this?
I might need to get cough drops.
I'm sorry.
Everything came together.
I need a cough drop.
Professional event announcements I've ever done.
I'm very sorry.
Um...
Actually, the most professional event announcement.
This is...
Alright, so...
Literally, it is next week.
It is next week.
So, it's gonna be on a Saturday for NA.
And now you're wondering...
Why are you organizing this custom?
Well...
Let me head off to...
The slides real quick.
It's slide time!
It's...
I mean, you guys already knew the time.
Like, it was on the forum.
But!
It's slides time!
For the information!
Oh my god, here we go!
Alright!
Sorry, the music stopped instantly.
But I'll add it back in.
Don't worry.
I think it was source 7.
I think it was this one.
Yes, there we go.
Alright!
So...
I'm gonna be calling our...
Our JP guy.
Real quick.
So...
When we get to the Japanese slides...
We're gonna call our JP translator to read it out in Japanese for those who are here.
Because we do have JP participants in this custom.
For those who don't know...
This custom is not a serious custom!
It's not like...
It's not like a really serious custom regarding...
I mean, there is prize money.
But I'll talk about that more later.
But...
This is more so...
Something where there's fun game modes.
There's a lot of players in here.
They're not Apex players.
Or like...
They're not pro.
They're more casual.
They never hit like Diamond or maybe like Plat or anything.
But they really like playing Apex.
So...
Because of that...
This is actually my very first time...
Not first time, but like...
As Jokey.
Organizing a more competitive esport-ish...
Esport type of...
Event.
And...
Because of this.
This is like a pilot episode.
This is essentially like a pilot.
Regarding like...
How...
How is...
No, no, okay.
How difficult is it to organize NA VTubers to come together?
And I learned today.
It is very difficult.
Not even today.
The last month...
Is incredibly difficult.
So...
Yes, we're...
We're trying our best here.
Anyway.
So, by the way.
This is not just NA VTubers.
They're VTubers in Asia.
In different parts of Asia.
And we slip in some Europeans in here.
Because like...
You know, it's my custom.
Like, it's my rules.
Literally, we told them.
Are you cool playing with three...
They're like, we want to play with this person.
Like, the captain would be like...
I know you said no Europeans.
But like...
I really want to play with this person.
And I was like...
Okay, let me ask Tempo.
Let me ask Oversight.
And Oversight was like...
They're gonna get 300 ping.
So then, I went back and I was like...
They're gonna play with 300 ping.
Are you sure?
And they're like...
Yeah, they're cool with that.
So, if they fucking complain about the ping.
That's on them.
We warned them.
We were very clear.
About the ping situation.
So, I weaved the rules regarding...
Regarding, like, allowing European players.
If the captains wanted to play with a European player.
Then fine.
You got this.
If you're wondering if there's any European pros.
Nope, because they're smarter than that.
They're...
The European pro players.
That are currently in active ALGS.
They were like...
No.
They're like...
You know...
If anybody...
Pro players would definitely complain about the ping.
So, they're just like...
No, fuck that shit.
Anyway.
This is a collaboration with Oversight.
For those who don't know what Oversight is.
They're basically...
The official organizers of...
Majority of the well-known scrims going on.
With ALGS and BLGS.
So, like, international scrims and everything.
That's why Tempo was like...
Yeah, like, if they are not...
They're afraid of me.
It was so smooth sailing.
Getting NA pros in here, by the way.
It was actually, like, one of the fucking easiest things.
Throughout the entire thing.
Because, like...
He was just like...
You want in?
Yeah, fucking get in here.
So...
They're very well-known within the Apex Legends scene.
And they helped us with getting...
Lots of well-known pros you might recognize.
In this custom.
So, yes.
We're gonna see that later on.
This will be officially sponsored.
I can't say it yet.
Because I'm still negotiating.
We're...
Still in the middle of negotiations.
With our sponsor.
So, we'll be announcing the sponsor at a later time.
At a later time.
During the custom.
So...
It's actually...
It's a really big deal.
So...
We were originally not gonna have any sponsors.
But...
In the end, we managed to...
They were like...
You know what?
We wanna do something with you and your custom.
And so...
But we're still in negotiations right now.
So...
I can't reveal who it is.
I can't reveal what they're gonna be helping out with.
But...
You'll find out at a later date.
Because I was like...
Are you guys actually gonna do it?
And they were like...
Yeah, we will.
We just need to like...
Talk with like...
Legal.
So...
They will be helping out.
Just...
We haven't...
We haven't like...
You know...
Finished negotiating.
And it will be done soon.
Anyway...
For also...
Another point...
Is that...
Nicewig and Greek...
Who are very well known in the scene...
For casting the BLGS...
And regarding like...
The B-Stream...
Within ALGS...
They will be casting...
The custom.
They will also be doing interviews.
So I thought this would be a great idea.
Because especially...
Especially with the sake...
With a lot of JP players.
A lot of JP VTubers...
Are gonna have a chance...
To talk to Nicewig and Greek.
They're gonna...
We're gonna be bringing them in...
To my voice channel.
And we're gonna...
Whoever...
People who win the custom...
Like each game...
Each game is a winner.
So each winner of each game...
Within the custom...
Will have a chance...
To be able to talk to the official casters...
Of ALGS.
So...
That was an opportunity I thought...
Would be amazing opportunity...
For people.
And I figured like...
For those who really wanted to meet Nicewig...
And Greek.
Especially when there's language...
Language differences.
We will have a translator there.
For them.
To help translate the conversation.
And that was like an opportunity I wanted to offer to people.
Especially with the language differences.
Not a lot of people get to talk to Wig.
Not a lot of people get to talk to Greek.
When it comes to like...
You know...
VTubers and casual streamers.
A lot of pros get to talk to him.
I talk to Wig all the fucking time.
But like...
That's just favoritism.
Like...
So...
But like...
I'm trying to give this opportunity to others.
Who maybe like you know...
Idolize Wig and Greek.
Be able to actually talk to them.
And stuff.
Yeah, that's called being friends.
Bestie privileges.
Anyway...
So...
The reason why I organized this custom.
Was because...
You guys didn't know.
The champions.
The ALGS champs.
Is being currently hosted.
In Japan.
So...
Basically like you know...
I heard that...
I heard that like...
Tickets already sold out really fast.
For the ALGS champs lan.
So...
Which was crazy.
Cause like you know...
It was supposed to be like...
It sold out really fast and everything.
And...
I also wanted a chance to unite...
Vtubers from around the world.
Whether they're indie or corporate.
Or they're pro or casual.
Or even if like you know...
They're big streamers or small streamers.
It was very hard.
I tried to balance out this custom.
With small streamers.
Big streamers.
Indies.
Companies.
So like when people...
When I had like you know...
People dropping out.
And stuff.
Or like they weren't allowed to participate.
Or something.
I tried to match it with...
Somebody that's similar.
That's similar numbers.
Similar like...
Like NA or APAC.
Or anything.
Just like...
Just to make sure.
That it's sort of balanced and everything.
And...
It was very difficult.
I have like...
Three fucking emergency backups.
Just in case this happens again.
Like...
I had...
Like at that point.
I was just like...
Bro fuck.
Fuck.
When I had to grab like...
Somebody.
Confirm somebody.
Like three hours ago.
Or like four hours ago.
I was just like...
Oh fuck this.
I'm gonna get like...
Three extra backups.
Just in case something happens.
On the 30th.
So...
Yeah.
So like...
I have like a lot back.
Anyway.
Like I said.
This is...
We wanna create like a funny event.
We don't get a lot of these types of events.
In NA.
Or English speaking events by the way.
You know.
We see a lot of that in Japan.
We...
We see a lot of these types of events in Japan and everything.
And...
But we don't see this a lot in NA.
So this is like...
Since like...
You know.
I thought APEX would be...
This would have been the easiest.
But silly me.
I need to fucking get 60 players.
I was like...
This is gonna be my test run.
To see if like...
To see if I can do it.
See if I can organize these types of events.
I chose APEX as the first one.
As my first pilot episode.
Because I thought...
You know.
Since I came from an APEX background.
And like...
You know.
I have Temple here to help me regarding finding pro players.
It wouldn't be that bad.
But then...
This was one of the hardest things I ever organized.
I...
Literally don't think I've done something as stressful as this before.
Because you would think...
That...
When you invite a captain.
They do the rest of the work.
That was not the case for some of the...
Some of the...
Some of the things that happened.
I had to like...
Piece teams together.
And be like...
Meet your new friend.
Because sometimes I had people that were like...
I can't get a plus one.
And I'd be like...
This is your new friend now.
You're gonna be playing with them for three to four hours on Saturday.
Good luck.
So...
Yeah.
So I had to do that a lot.
It wasn't that easy when you give like somebody a captain spot.
And like...
They get...
You know.
They get the plus one.
Sometimes I had to get the plus one.
So...
There's that.
Anyway.
This one goes okay.
I'd love to organize more customs themed around competitive games.
It's a lot easier...
Um...
Doing events that are not based off competitive.
Because...
Like even...
I won't...
I won't categorize as Minecraft events as competitive.
Because that's something I'm...
I'm planning on in 2025.
Like a...
A big Minecraft event.
Um...
Because like...
Everybody plays Minecraft.
And you can divide it by skill level very easily.
And like you don't...
It doesn't have to be like very competitively.
Apex on the other hand...
Not everybody plays Apex.
And...
Not everyone would...
Um...
Especially in NA.
It's very limited.
When it comes to like...
Um...
People who are interested in these types of events.
So...
It was incredibly hard...
Much harder to find participants.
And I had to find like...
Well not 60.
Because we do have...
I had to find like...
You know...
30 other players.
Because I assumed...
No actually 40 players.
Because like 20 of them were pro players.
Um...
Because each team...
Not even...
No.
It's like 50.
Because like not every team...
Not every team wanted a pro player.
Some teams are full VTuber teams by the way.
Um...
So...
There's also that too.
Um...
So yes.
It was very difficult.
And...
Through this...
I will see...
How we go about organizing more competitive ones.
I'm actually in talks...
Regarding organizing a...
Maybe an FGC type thing.
So like...
From this...
I'm learning from this right now.
On how to make something better for FGC.
So...
So I'm learning from this at the moment.
Won't be 60 players though.
At least...
In that area...
It won't be 60 players.
Um...
Because FGC...
Especially Street Fighter...
Is incredibly popular in Japan...
In the VTubing sphere right now.
So I noticed that.
So like...
I'm using this as like...
To figure out how the fuck to...
Do something similar.
Anyway...
Let's...
Get our...
I'm sorry...
JP...
JP bro...
I'm sorry.
I know like...
Um...
I'm gonna call you now.
I'm gonna call our translator now.
By the way...
He's gonna be like...
Translating this on his phone.
Hey.
Hey Dash.
Wait a sec.
Yeah, I got the summary up.
By the way, this is Dash.
He's our official translator guy.
If you guys don't know him...
He was the sub for RPR's BLGS team.
And he translates a lot for other...
Apex tournaments.
So yeah.
That's Dash.
Hello, hello, hello.
Do you guys hear me?
Oh my god.
He's on his phone right now.
I'm sorry.
Okay, let me explain.
Let me explain first.
I didn't know that I have to explain...
Stream.
Wait, I told you!
Okay, that's a miscommunication.
That was like a miscommunication, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So yeah, I know, I know.
That was my bad.
But like, I didn't know that.
So I'm in the friend's house in the toilet.
Oh, you're in the...
So yeah.
And my friend's literally playing the BLGS right now.
Oh shit!
Wait, he's playing BLGS right now?
How is he doing?
I don't know.
He's like in round 3 or something.
He looks like he's doing great, I guess.
Oh shit, sweet.
Yes, and so I'm on the phone.
I'm using my wireless earbuds.
And that sounds really bad, I'm sorry.
But yeah, I'm...
I literally translated this...
Yeah, he translated this when he got back.
And he was like, shit, I didn't realize.
And I was like, what do you think the slides are for?
I had to do this like this morning.
I woke up.
I see this part.
Oh shit!
You know?
Alright, so...
Alright, Japanese listeners.
I really apologize.
I hope you're able to hear what he says.
But yes, you go do your thing, Dash.
Okay.
Konnichiwa.
I'm Dash.
This time, I'm going to be translating.
Okay.
So, this is a documentary.
It's a collaboration between BLGS and ALGS.
It's a collaboration between the two organizations.
We don't have any official sponsors.
We'll announce the sponsors when we get to them.
Okay.
Yay!
This is a test event, so there will be other events besides Apex, like Valorant, Street Fighter, League of Legends, and other competitive eSports titles, so please look forward to it.
Do I just call you after I'm done for each slide, or will you just be listening?
Am I supposed to hit the toilet for entry time, or what?
Wait, what?
Am I supposed to stay in the bathroom for whole time?
Okay.
Sorry, we have our translator in the bathroom.
Toilet live translation.
Guys, like I said, everybody, like, we had a lot of issues.
Like her said, we missing like two pro players, right?
Yeah, yeah, I told them that story.
Yeah, and Dash, we found our final pro player literally like five hours ago.
Yeah, yeah, for your warning, we found the last pro player like five hours ago.
So like, anything that could go wrong sort of went wrong, so like, we have our translator in the fucking bathroom.
Exactly.
That's one of the problems.
Because of unfortunate miscommunication there.
Sorry, I didn't realize that you were at your friend's place.
I don't want anyone to like, what, hold these tournaments or even, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, he's getting paid by the way, guys.
He's not doing it for free.
He's like, I'm getting paid, right?
And I was like...
But yes, by the way, here's the hashtag too, by the way.
It's gonna be DokiOversight2024.
I just realized I forgot to include the hashtag.
But thank you, Dash.
You can, I'll call you when, you can go to the bathroom whenever.
I don't know which is easier for you.
Do I call you whenever I'm ready for you or you want to stay in the bathroom?
Um, should I just mute in here?
Yeah, sure, you can mute in the bathroom, yeah.
Alright, yeah, he's gonna be muted in the bathroom until I call him in.
Anyway, so, sorry.
That should say rules, by the way, not nerfs.
But I hope for those who are JP listeners, I know I'm speaking in English.
But, like, for those who know Japanese and English, I hope that the translation has been okay so far.
And that you guys are able to hear it.
Anyway, this is supposed to say rules.
Anyway, like I said, there will be four fun game modes and two regular matches.
We're gonna start off with the normal games on World's Edge.
Melee abilities only on Stormpoint.
Protect the princess in E-District.
Hide and seek on Broken Moon.
Sniper only in E-District.
And Launch Royale on King's Canyon.
These are our six games.
Now, teams, for the landmarks, we're not gonna be doing the landmarks on stream.
Like, deciding landmarks.
That takes too much time.
So, I'm gonna fucking spin the wheel off stream.
And then whatever happens to them happens.
We're gonna have the official Apex server code because Oversight organizes scrims very regularly.
So, for those who've never watched tournaments in Apex Legends, teams don't drop off and then they have to fly to the landmarks.
They spawn into the landmark.
So, like, you know, they just spawn in and everything.
And what we can do is that for the four fun game modes, you're just gonna spawn in randomly.
Like, you can do that with an official Apex server code.
So, we literally click randomize and we don't know who's gonna get what.
We don't know who's gonna be getting what landmark.
Not even me because we're doing it live.
But the normal game modes, which is gonna be number one and six, we're gonna have assigned landmarks.
But we're gonna spin the wheel.
So, at least they know where it's gonna be.
Anyway, prizes.
I know a lot of you guys are freaking out about the prizes.
So, the reason I am personally funding this custom.
Yes, it is $30,000 of my own money.
That's not from the sponsor.
It might even be more if the sponsor, like, after negotiations with the sponsor.
But it is $30,000 of my own money.
It's not like I'm fucking bathing in money right now.
But the reason why is that I wanted to encourage people.
I never really was public about, like, what the prizes were when people were invited.
Literally, people found out what the prizes were when they joined the server.
So, it was a little, like, surprise, you know.
Actually, the only people that knew were the pros.
Because money is... the pros would only really join due to the money.
So, only the pros knew about the money prizes.
Because it was the way to incentivize the pros to join as well.
Because of that, we wanted to give this opportunity.
Especially, a lot of these players are giving up their own time to participate.
This is why I always wanted an event.
I just wanted, you know, a way to, like, have, like, memories from the event.
And being able to, you know, get something physical from it.
If you do really well.
Because, like, you know, I get it.
You did well.
You can brag about it.
But it's all, like, you know, that's really it.
You got the stream memories from it.
But I always wanted, like, something physical that you can look back on physically.
If you can look at something.
So, I contacted Gamersubs if they were interested in providing medals to the winners.
At first, I was like, I'll pay you guys.
Because I knew they've made me, like, the enamel pins in the past.
Like, memorabilia.
So, like, for WrestleTuber, I think I've shown you guys this before in the past.
But for WrestleTuber, they made...
I actually showed this in the official server.
The custom server.
But for those who don't know.
Everybody that participates is gonna get a pin that's based off of the logo.
And for those who don't know what it looks like.
I'm gonna pull it up real quick, guys.
I have to save it.
Because I just realized that's like...
So, this is what it looks like that they've made for me.
For WrestleTuber.
So, everybody that participated basically received this pin.
Some people didn't receive it because, like, they never replied back to me.
So, like...
So, it would be like this.
But with the logo for this custom.
So, every player, all 60 players will receive something like this.
If they reply back to me and my management and Gamersubs.
So, like, some people might not receive it.
Because, you know, they never replied back.
Or they never filled in the form.
We tried to, like, make sure everybody filled it in.
But, like, you know, if they didn't get it.
Like, we can't wait forever.
So, I asked Gamersubs if they could do something like this again.
And I was willing to pay for it.
Because, like, you know.
I actually asked them, like, two to three weeks.
Two weeks ago, I believe.
I asked them two weeks ago if they could.
Because we were trying to look for, like, ways to create more memories for people who participate.
And they were like...
At first, I was like, I can pay you guys.
But then they were like, no, we'll do it for free.
Like, we can do it for free for you.
And so, they'll be producing medals for all the teams that win first place.
Every individual that wins first place will get medals and prize money.
And second place will also receive physical prizes from our sponsor.
So, they might not receive the money.
But they'll receive some physical prizes.
So, at least they get something.
So, it's not just first place.
But, yeah.
That's basically the rules.
Yes, huge thank you to Gamersubs.
Did you guys know my Gamersub drop is out now?
And you can support me with me funding more events like this.
Also, by the way, the prize money thing, it's not gonna be a thing.
It's not gonna be something common throughout my events.
The biggest reason why I have a prize money is for the pros.
Because, like, the pros, you know, they're giving up their own time.
And they don't make a lot of money in general.
So, like...
Really, that prize money was, like, for them.
For participating.
That's why.
Because, you know, they have to, like...
So, that's why I did it for them.
Just to incentivize them to join.
But, yeah.
Anyway...
But, I feel like, you know, I really wanted to help out in the community and everything.
Anyway, but yes, if you guys didn't know, I do have a Gamersub drop out right now.
Yes, oh my god, yes, Cactus, that's right.
Can you post that again so I can pin that message?
We actually found it.
Alright, here you go, guys.
Make sure to use my code, by the way.
It actually helps out a lot more.
Anyway...
Anyway, Dash, go get in here.
We need you to do your bathroom translation.
Yeah, if I'm back, toilet Dash is there.
Oh, look, there's rules right there, by the way.
There it is.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to...
Let me add the JP version.
Thank you.
Thanks for staying in the bathroom.
Yes.
Alright, wait, which one is it?
Is it this one?
Oh, it's this one, I found it.
Alright, let me move it up.
What happened to my JP slide?
Well, we'll never know.
There we go.
We're trying our best here with what we got.
There, we got it.
Wait, it's...
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, that's it.
Alright.
Basically, it's random, so I don't think the winning rate will change that much.
And the prize is...
I wonder what it is.
It's $3, so in Japanese yen, it's about 4.65 million yen.
30K!
Yeah!
Let's go!
I was weak!
Only if you win, though.
Only if you win.
But don't worry, they all have 6 chances to win.
Anyway...
Alright, so, there's gonna be nerfs!
Yes!
Nerfs!
So, because...
We literally told them there's no rank limit.
Because, like...
The thing about NA is that...
There's not a lot of, like...
NA Apex VTubers that are well-known.
Especially in the higher ELO.
So, like...
When you ask, like...
People for captain spots...
It's a lot difficult.
Because, like...
For them, they're like, who do I get?
Especially if the restriction is VTubers.
So, because of that, we were like, no rank limit.
But, if you stack up your fucking team...
They have a decision to stack it up or not.
But we realized, a lot of the teams...
They decided not to stack up their team.
They just wanted to play for fun.
So, because of that, we were like...
If you hit any...
If you hit master in any season...
Yes, there's teams that...
There's actually, like...
A team or two that doesn't really play...
Like, doesn't...
Are, like, casual Apex players.
So, like, they were like, we don't want a pro.
But they're all, like, casual Apex players.
So, we were like, if you fucking stack up your team...
And have all your team is, like, a pro and two master players...
We're fucking slapping you down.
Because we want everybody to have fun.
So, because of that, if you are a master plus player...
You're gonna have to only use one gun.
So, each player has one gun.
Because we want the more casual teams to have fun, you know?
So, and if game one...
You fucking kill half the lobby.
If I see a team kill, like, ten plus people...
Like, if one person gets, like, so many fucking kills where half the lobby is down...
The lobby will decide their fate.
So, after the games...
After game one, if a lobby was like...
We're gonna fuck...
We want this team to get absolutely stuffed down.
And then we all decide as a lobby together...
On what restrictions we're gonna place on them...
On game six.
So, that's how the nerfs are gonna...
I mean, if they win first...
Like, if they already won first place...
Like, in game six, like, at that point...
We all decide in game six, like, how it's gonna be.
So,
we're all gonna pass judgment.
Like, especially if they won...
And they killed the majority of the lobby...
We're slapping you down.
But it'll be affect only game six.
It's not like it's gonna affect every game.
It's just gonna be for game six.
So, yeah.
That's basically the nerf.
Whoops.
Oh, that's where the rules went.
Where the fuck?
How in the... Okay, sorry.
I realized I named my slides wrong.
Sorry, Dash.
Let me grab the actual nerf.
Wait, did I even saved it?
I must have, right?
Oh, no.
Wait.
Dash, can you just read off...
Wait, I don't have it saved.
I forgot to...
I knew I forgot one thing.
Wait, is it this one?
Wait, I can't read it.
No, no, no.
No, I got another one, but I can't read it...
Because it's all in Japanese.
Wait, is it this one?
I think I found it.
I think I found it, Dash.
Is it this one?
It's in Japanese.
I can't tell.
Is it this?
Come on, come on.
Oh, that one.
There we go.
Yeah, we did it.
Sorry, I can't read this.
This is why I have a Japanese translator.
Alright, there you go.
It's exactly why.
Alright.
Yeah, thank you, bathroom translator.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, so...
Alright, anyway.
Next up, we have...
Match 1.
Alright, this is really easy.
Match 1, it's a regular match.
I don't have to talk much details.
It's gonna be World's Edge.
Toll kills do not matter.
It's about the end result.
So, whatever happens at the end, where there's one winner, that's the team that's winning $5,000.
And you have to divide it by three people, by the way.
So, like, each person gets $1,600 and a medal.
And the second place will get prizes that will be decided later after negotiations are over with the sponsor.
So, we have that.
Anyway, if they do too well in this match, the winner, they will get slapped in match 6.
So, that's what's gonna happen.
They're gonna get fucking slapped down.
Master Plus players can only carry one gun each.
And I know somebody was like, what about the akimbo, the dual P20 and mozamb?
We're trying to make sure people have fun here.
And if you ask any Apex player if they enjoy getting shot down by dual mozambs or dual P20s, you will all get the same answer.
And you guys all know that answer.
Anyway, alright, Dash.
Dash?
Were you peeing?
No, I'm not.
I'm literally standing here.
It's match 1.
Alright, there we go.
Like I said, only one player can carry a gun.
And if the team is too strong, like if they are a champion or a premix, there will be restrictions on the number of guns.
And if you win, you will receive $5000 plus medals.
For the second place team, we are still looking at the details, but you will get a prize from the sponsor.
Alright.
Alright, thank you Dash.
Alright, match 2.
Thank you.
By the way guys, was he loud enough?
I know I should have asked this when we first started having him translate.
But is he okay?
Is the volume okay?
Is his volume okay guys?
Uh, no idea.
I don't know Japanese.
Alright, for those who understand Japanese, he's good?
Yeah.
Anyway, match 2.
It's gonna be on Stormpoint.
It's gonna be melee abilities only.
So, um, we're gonna have people fisting and using abilities.
But, you cannot use grenades.
You cannot use grenades.
And it can't be damaging abilities or ults.
Um, so, um, apparently, um, I didn't realize this, but Dash was like, cause he's like an Apex translator.
He was like, what about Newcastle?
And I was like, what the fuck do you mean what about Newcastle?
Just don't use your ult.
But then he was like, yeah, but what about his Q?
And I got really confused.
I was like, what do you mean by his Q?
You mean that mobile shield that moves around?
And apparently, if you guys didn't, I didn't know this, but if you throw his fucking mobile shield at somebody before it lands, it does damage.
Right, you cunt?
I didn't know that.
That happened.
Apparently, it's been there since launch.
It's been there since launch.
So, I was like, you know what?
Fuck it.
You can play, you can use Newcastle's Q.
Because I think it would be really funny if you died to his shield.
That's really it.
So, I was like, that's fine.
Just don't ult.
I don't care.
If you throw his fucking Q at people, that's pretty funny if you die from it.
So, Newcastle is allowed.
Somebody would be like, what about Bangalore's smoke?
You see, I thought about that too.
But I also got called out on that.
Because that was in the rules initially.
And Dash was like, you know they patched that out, right?
So, for those who are like, what about Bangalore's smoke?
You revealed yourself today.
As not keeping up with the patches, just like me.
So, that's patched out.
So, you can use Bangalore's smoke too.
Anyway, the last surviving team is the winner.
And the prizes are the same.
5,000 divided by 3 players.
And medals plus second place prizes.
Alright, Dash, your turn.
Wait, why does that say King's Canyon?
Sorry, that's supposed to be Stormpoint.
Sorry.
That's supposed to be Stormpoint, guys.
Oh, that's 20?
Bro, what?
I thought it was 10.
In the kill feed, it shows your castle kills somebody with the mobile skill.
Which is kind of crazy.
But, yeah, okay.
Anyway.
Match 2.
I'm playing King's Canyon.
And this is Stormpoint.
In this match 2, only melee attacks and abilities are allowed.
Weapons are not allowed.
Only melee attacks and abilities are allowed.
Damage is limited to abilities.
For example, Valkyrie's Curse.
Or Corsica's Curse.
Those are basically not allowed.
However, you can use Newcastle's Curse.
Newcastle's Curse deals 20 damage to the enemy before the shield appears.
You can throw it.
If you defeat the enemy, you can throw it.
However, you can't use the ultimate skill.
You'll get knocked back.
You can't use the ultimate skill.
And this is the same as the last match.
It doesn't matter how many kills you get.
The last survivor is the winner.
The prize is the same as the last match.
1st place is $5,000.
And the medal.
2nd place is the prize.
I won't tell you the details.
That's it.
Yeah!
Thank you, Dash.
Time for match number 3.
Yes, modern problems require modern solutions, guys.
Thank God we're live.
Match 3.
Sniper only.
We're going to make sure that it's going to be on E-District.
The fucking land of snipers.
We all love E-District.
Anyway.
We're going to have it so that nobody's going to attack each other.
Until after the ring closes for round 1.
So the moment the ring hits that circle, we're fucking attacking each other.
So that's how it's going to go.
So people are going to be able to find sniper and sniper ammo in time.
Before it hits.
If you are masters plus, you're not allowed to melee anybody.
And can only use one sniper.
But, if you're below masters, you can melee.
Because in my head, I thought it'd be so funny if we see three people fucking...
I hope we would see three people run up to a sniper and just start punching.
So, that's why I was like, okay, that'll be really funny.
So, that's why, if you're masters plus, you can't do that.
But if you're below masters, I mean, if you have a team filled with master players.
You should be able to kill them, right?
Before they get to you.
Like, they're going to be running straight at you.
Unless they actually...
It'd be funny to see somebody, like three people hide in the corner.
Waiting for a sniper to show up and then just beat the shit out of them.
I thought it would be really funny.
But anyway.
But grenades are not allowed.
And there's no wingman.
And you can use the Kraber.
And abilities and ults can be used, but we're not allowing rampart.
Because, like, that's just cheating.
If you put your pro player on rampart.
Like, that's just, you know, that's just not here to have fun anymore.
Anyway, you can carry and use healing items.
And like I said, total kills do not matter.
And winner is the last team alive who wins champions.
Yes, I do have rules that I think would just be funny, okay?
Like, this is a content custom.
We're not here for that.
Like, it's each game is winning.
Each game, you have a chance to win something.
It's not like an overall ALGS shit.
I just think it's... I make rules based off of will it be funny.
Because, like, if anything, I could see that, like...
I could see, like, three people from the teams with no pros.
They'll just hide in a corner waiting for somebody.
Waiting for maybe a pro player to walk in.
I thought it'd be really funny if they all just started crawling on it.
Anyway...
Anyway, that is the third match.
Prizes are the same.
Prizes are the same throughout it.
So, 5,000 plus medals and TBD prizes.
Yes, Vantage is okay.
Bocek is not a sniper.
It's... We just said, yes, Kraber.
That's really it.
Alright, your turn, Dash.
Alright.
I just realized that I didn't add...
Oh, wait.
No more.
It's actually fine.
Okay.
Oh,
it's E-District, by the way.
Sorry.
That's my bad.
I forgot to change the map in the JP translation, but we'll do it live.
The players in E-District are not allowed to use melee attacks.
You can only use melee attacks on snipers.
However, players under Master can use melee attacks.
You can also surround Master players and beat them up.
You can't use grenades.
You can't use Wingman, Lampard, or Seer.
You can only use Kraber, Ability, and Lampard's Ultimate.
Other than Lampard's Ultimate, you can't use anything else.
You can't use Phase either.
You can only use Recovery.
It doesn't matter how many times you use it.
The last one you can use is the Champion.
The prize is $5,000 plus a medal.
$5,000 plus a medal.
Rules for Hiders.
Hiders are not allowed to hurt and damage other Hiders or Seekers.
There are no weapons, melees, grenades, or damaging abilities.
However, you can carry and use healing items.
The Seekers will be my team.
It will be me, Altair, and Jen Burden.
I don't think Jen is going to watch this stream.
When we asked, they were like, which pro do you want?
And I was like, how about Verhulst?
But I forgot because I figured it would be like a reunion.
But then, apparently, next week is American Thanksgiving.
And he's not going to be here.
So, I was like, let's get Jen Burden in here.
And I was like, alright, cool.
And then Tempo asked Jen.
Jen was like, aw man, I'm still in Australia.
I don't think I can do it.
And then, so he was like, nah.
And then I told Tempo, tell him it's on my team.
Because I was like, did you tell him it would be on my team that I requested Jen?
And he was like, no.
Alright, tell him it would be on my team.
And then later on, Tempo was like, yeah, Jen's going to be playing.
So, I'm going to fucking, I don't think he's watching this right now.
But on the day, I'm going to call him out on that.
I don't think he knows that I knew he rejected first.
Anyway, we are not going to be allowed to play Pathfinder, Bloodhound, Seer, Valkyrie, or Crypto.
And the last Hider team that survives this is going to win, basically.
So, like I said, these prizes are going to be for the Hiders.
The Seekers, we're going to have our little own competition.
What I'm thinking right now, I'm fucking trying to think of this live.
Is that Altair and I are going to compete against Jen on who is going to find the most Hiders.
And whoever is going to win, is going to win something.
Why is it Altair and I combined versus Jen?
Literally, he's a fucking pro player.
Like, what do you want?
What do you want from us?
He's literally pro.
We have to work together.
Like, we have to work together.
So, Altair and I, it's going to be Altair and I versus Jen.
And we'll see who can kill the most Hiders.
So, that's how it's going to be.
These prizes, same prizes, 5000 plus medals.
And then second place will be to be decided.
Alright, Dash.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
Okay, match 4.
You got the slide?
Yeah, it's right here.
By the way, it says King's Canyon again, but I'm going to change it.
It's supposed to be Broken Moon.
Let's go.
Alright, game 4.
So, the first game is Hide and Seek.
It's going to be in Broken Moon.
In Broken Moon, the Hiding Team and the Demon Team are going to be in Team 1.
Team 1 is Altair, Jen, Dash, and Rokka.
These three are going to be looking for the Hiding Team.
As for the Hiding Team, the Hiding Team is not allowed to attack or deal damage to other Hiding Team or Seeking Team.
Weapons, melee attacks, grenades, damage-dealing abilities, and ultimate skills are also not allowed.
However, you can get healing items, so you can heal and run away.
You can also heal and run away after taking damage.
As for the Demon Team, you are not allowed to scan enemy characters such as Pathfinder, Bloodhound, Seer, Valkyrie, and Priestess.
As for the winning conditions, the winning team will receive $5,000, a medal, and a prize.
As for the Demon Team, as Doki just said,
Altair and Doki's total number of kills and Jen's total number of kills will be decided by the three of them.
The reason is that Jen's total number of kills is close.
And that's about it.
Next slide.
Game 5.
It's not Broken Moon, guys.
It's another E-District.
Because Game 5 is Protect the Princess.
What do you mean by that?
Well, basically, like I said, Master Plus players can only carry one gun.
Pro players, if you have a pro player on your team, you will be a mandatory princess.
Because I thought it would be funny.
Anyway, you know, just like neuter them, basically.
You're like, I'm a pro, but I can't do anything.
Anyway, so the princess cannot carry...
And I thought it would be funny to call them princesses too.
We're like, protect the princess.
Anyway, the princess cannot carry any guns or use grenades.
But they can carry grenades for their teammates.
And they can use their abilities, including damaging abilities.
So, the princess cannot play Rampart or Vantage.
If the princess full dies, if they get knocked, they're fine.
You just revive them.
But if they're full killed, as in they're dead, dead, you can't revive them at all.
You can't rez them too, by the way.
No rezes are allowed.
So, they have to be like, full death, your fucking team's out.
You drop all your weapons, you go W key over there with nothing.
Because you failed your job.
So, basically, total kills do not matter.
And the winner is the last team alive, who wins champion.
So, yeah, that's basically protect the princess.
You gotta make sure your player doesn't die.
If you don't have a pro on your team, you can pick whoever your princess is.
But, if you have a designated pro player on your team, it's your pro player.
So, you gotta protect them, basically.
Alright, Dash, your turn.
And while you're talking... Oh, it's King's Canyon again, but it's not, by the way.
It's E-District.
It's just all King's Canyon, by the way, guys.
It's literally just all King's Canyon.
If you translate this, I'm gonna...
Alright, I'm kinda sure.
If you have a designated pro player on your team, you can only use one weapon.
You can't do any damage to your princess.
Basically, you can't even fly with Valkyrie.
If you have a team without a pro player on your team, you can pick whoever your princess is.
But, if you have a designated pro player on your team, you can only use one weapon.
So, you gotta protect the other two VTubers.
You can't even play Valkyrie with Valkyrie or Vantage.
If your princess is completely defeated, the entire team is defeated.
The reason is that you've already failed the mission.
This is also the same.
The last survivor is the champion.
The prize is $5000 and a medal.
The prize is sponsored by the sponsor.
That's it.
You have no power here.
Thank you, Dash.
We have one last slide.
It's the easiest one.
It's actually King's Canyon.
Finally.
This is gonna be Launch Royale.
For those who don't know what Launch Royale is, it's basically Apex Season 0-1.
It'll be the beginning season where it all started.
We're actually on King's Canyon this time.
The nerfs are in place from game 1.
If your team gets targeted by the lobby...
If the entire lobby was down with this team...
You're gonna be affected by the nerfs.
Like always, Masters Plus players can only carry one gun.
Plus additional nerfs coming into place depending on what the lobby decides.
Yes, it is available in Custom Lobby.
Tempo was the one that brought it up to me.
So that's why we're like, it'll be fun to end it off.
Bring back the memories and everything.
Like I said, total kills do not matter.
And the winner is the last team alive who wins Champion.
Alright, Dash.
The last translation from the bathroom.
And then you can cheer on your friend.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
This is Game 6.
This is the last match.
This rule is Launch Royale.
If you're playing Apex, I'm sure you've already played Launch Royale.
For those of you who don't know what it is, Launch Royale is a game mode that's currently being played in Apex.
In Launch Royale, you go back to Season 0.
All weapons, characters, etc.
All of them go back to their original state.
In this rule, you can only carry one weapon.
If you're a Master or above.
You can only carry one weapon.
For teams that are too strong, like Match 1, there is a chance that you will be penalized by the lobby.
This also has nothing to do with total kills.
The last team to survive is the winner.
The prize is $5,000.
And the medal.
The winner will receive the prize from the sponsor.
Alright.
Yay!
We did it!
Alright, Dash.
You can leave now.
Thanks for being here.
I really appreciate the live translation.
It helps a lot.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
Call me out anytime.
I'm gonna make sure there's no more mistranslations this time.
It's okay.
It's my fan.
Alright, thank you.
Thank you, Dash.
Alright, goodbye.
Say goodbye to Dash for us, guys.
Say goodbye to Dash, everybody.
He's gonna leave the bathroom now.
Yes, finally.
I'm opening the door.
Alright, bye, Dash.
Bye.
Alright.
Yay!
Thanks, Dash.
Really appreciate it.
Alright, anyway.
It is time to announce the teams.
Alright.
Okay, so.
We sort of spoiled the first team already.
So, let me add the music back in.
Because I didn't add the music for this one.
By the way, I don't know if you guys realized this.
It might be very obvious that I sort of came up with the team name.
Literally after a collab.
Because I thought it fit very well.
What I was going through that day.
So, we are...
My team is...
The IRS.
So, it's gonna be me, Altair, and Jen Burton from 100 Thieves.
So, yeah.
By the way, guys.
Not everybody has...
Yes, we're here to fucking take your taxes.
Taxman is here now.
The taxman is here.
Anyway.
What was I gonna say?
Oh my gosh, I lost my train of thought.
Okay, I remember.
Not everybody is gonna have a team name.
I told them.
Not everybody gave me their team name in time.
I didn't wanna poke them.
It was three strikes.
If I poke them three times regarding team names...
And I don't get a team name...
You're not getting a team name.
I have other stuff to do.
Also, same with images.
For some of them, I did like...
Forgot to like...
I forgot to ask Altair for like his PNG.
For others, I asked every captain.
For key visuals.
If you don't give me your key visuals...
I get to pick.
I get to pick the key visuals.
So like...
That's all I'm saying.
Anyway, team 2.
We have...
You will see their logos.
What org they're from.
What company they're from.
I thought it was a nice...
I had somebody design all these graphics.
But I did decide the composition and everything.
So...
Basically...
I thought it was a nice touch to show...
Like...
What company they're part of and everything.
So we have...
Ditto, Amatsuki, and Yuris for team 2.
And their name is Team Ditto.
She gave me key visuals though.
She did give me team visuals.
She just didn't give me the team name.
So they're called Team Ditto.
But yes, this is team number 2.
Team 3.
We have...
Nasi Goren.
Akemi from Aka Virtual.
By the way, like I said...
A lot of these teams are worldwide.
I tried to balance it as best as I could with APAC and NA.
And the two EU players that slipped in.
We have...
Akemi, Fonzy, and FunFPS from NRG.
A lot of these are also like...
We tried to balance with...
By the way, I know...
We did have like...
We weaved some...
We did weave some rules.
I know Fonzy might not be a VTuber.
But they were the last minute team I literally got yesterday.
So...
I was like...
Thank you for clutching it Akemi.
Because Akemi was like...
Can I bring Fonzy?
And I was like...
Look, I need a team in here.
Yes, Fonzy the piano guy.
Yes, FunFPS was already here.
Pros...
Pros we did great.
Pros was the easiest part for some reason.
Except for the last JP pro.
Trying to find the last JP pro.
Because like...
Timing wise was all over the place.
But like...
Rest of the pros we did great.
But it was just...
Trying to coordinate the others.
Anyway...
Yes, Fonzy is a VTuber now.
We weaved the rule because...
I was like...
24 hours to find a team.
He's the piano man.
And we got Akemi from...
Aka Virtual.
Yeah!
That's team 3.
This is a full 20 team lobby by the way.
We have full 20 teams.
I was serious when I said...
We got 60 players.
Team 4!
We have...
Yes, team Bao.
Bao, Uto, and...
Lia.
From FaZe Connect.
Yes, we have team Bao.
They want to make a full VTuber team.
I suggested if...
Originally, Uto was gonna be...
Her own captain.
But then...
We merged...
It was decided early on though.
It wasn't like...
Last minute merging or everything.
We just thought Bao really wanted to play with Uto.
And I was like...
Uto is a captain.
If you guys really want to play together...
That's fine.
So Uto gave up her captain slot...
To play with...
Bao and Lia.
Anyway...
That's team 4!
Team 5!
We have...
ChibiDoki, Nangs, and Ruben.
Yes!
This is a one VTuber team.
But...
ChibiDoki was like...
Ruben can be a VTuber.
And I said...
If Ruben puts on a VTuber model...
He can join in.
Nangs is...
Considered the pro player on their team.
Because I was like...
Chibi really wanted these two players on her team.
I'm the organizer.
So I was just like...
Fuck it.
I made a lot of exceptions by the way guys.
I...
He was...
Nangs was the pro.
Was the pro in their team.
She categorized him as the pro.
Because I was like...
Either a team of 3 VTubers...
Or you get a pro.
And she was like...
Can Nangs be the pro?
And I was like...
Sure.
But you gotta get another VTuber.
And she was like...
Can I get Ruben?
And I was like...
He'll use a PNG.
Okay.
But like...
What about he uses a VTuber model?
And she was like...
Okay.
So like...
Yeah.
Good enough.
So...
Like I said...
Usually I just gave them cactus slots.
And they just get the team together.
So this is team number 5.
And we have team 6.
We have Billion, NecroLina, and Monsoon.
Trying to find a pro...
By the way, their team name is Katnado.
By the way, trying to find a pro...
To match...
The rest of this team...
Was very hard.
We had to interview a few pros...
To be like...
Who can match...
This team?
Apparently...
From what I was told...
Monsoon is known as one of the crazier pros.
Not like crazy crazy.
But like...
Chaotic type deal.
Like a lot of pros were vouching...
That Monsoon...
Can like...
Match their freak.
And that he is pretty chaotic.
So Monsoon is the babysitter.
I don't know if he is going to be the babysitter.
But Monsoon from Complexity...
Is going to be playing with...
Fillion and Nekrolina.
On team Katnado.
And that's team 6.
Team 7.
Representing...
Billy Billy side.
I got Hiro.
Nachen.
And LD.
I'm sorry, I don't know the last character.
It's like...
I can't read that character.
But...
Hiro...
And her team is going to be...
Representing on Billy Billy's team.
Like I said, I wanted like...
I wanted this custom to be...
Everywhere.
And I wanted...
Everybody to like...
A lot of places to be represented.
So...
We have Hiro's Neko Punch.
Is their team name.
I'm sorry, I can't read that character.
I don't know what that says.
My Chinese is like...
Primary school level when it comes to reading.
But I can read...
That's all I can remember.
But he is a...
Pro player from...
From APAC.
So...
More catgirls.
That's right.
It wasn't supposed to be back to back catgirls.
But it just...
Happened that way.
Team 8.
We have from Holostars.
We have Team Armus.
So...
We have...
Gerard Goldbullet.
And CrimsonRuse.
That is Team 8.
They were like...
I was asking them.
I was like...
Do you guys need a pro player?
Gerard asked to join this custom.
And I was like...
Yeah, no problem man.
Do you want a pro player?
And he was like...
No, we are not going to win.
We just want to have fun.
And I was like...
Good for you.
So...
We have...
Gerard Goldbullet.
And CrimsonRuse.
In here on Team 8.
From Holostars.
Next up...
We have Team Kuro.
Ah yes, you see...
Our first...
One of our first...
Not first star.
We have a lot of rules exception here.
But...
We have Kuro and Michi.
From Vshojo.
And IPN.
The guy that is going to play on 300 ping.
And said he will be okay.
If this guy complains...
About the ping.
Anyway...
This is Team 9.
With Kuro, Michi and IPN.
Alright, Team 10.
We have...
Team FaZe Connect.
We have representing FaZe Connect.
We have...
Lumi and Ember.
And we got...
Lulu Lovely.
For those who don't know who Lulu Lovely is.
Lulu is very well known in the NA Apex scene.
She is...
She actually has her own gun skin in Apex.
If you don't know.
She is one of the most well known female players within NA.
And...
It was great to...
That she was open to joining this custom.
It was great about it.
Anyway...
Yes, Lulu will be on this team.
We assigned her to this team.
Alright, next up.
Team 11.
We have...
Kohaku's team.
So, we have Kohaku.
From Project Kawaii.
And she brought in...
Shiosaki.
And also, we have a Japanese pro.
His name is...
Sisu.
I can't remember what team he is from.
Dash helped us in getting him.
He is from XFC.
So, X Factor.
In Japan.
So, yes.
This is team 11.
Kohaku really wanted to play with a...
JP pro.
And we are happy to be able to...
Get the...
Get Sisu for them.
So, yes.
This is team 11.
Team 11.
Team 12.
We have...
Team Monster Lovers.
So, in Monster Lovers, we have...
Amelie.
And her friend, Miss Shadow Lovely.
And then, we assigned...
Albert Lele.
Who is also a VTuber now.
So, I couldn't find...
By the way...
This is me Googling their images.
And...
Mac does not have his...
I was tempted to just...
Go find his stream and then screenshot it.
Because I can't find it on...
Like, I couldn't find it on Google.
But like, he did post his reference sheet.
Which was great.
But I was so disclosed...
To just go to his stream and screenshot a picture of him.
Because you cannot find his VTuber model anywhere.
Like, not on Google.
Not on Google Images.
So...
Anyway.
So that is Team Monster Lovers.
Of Amelie, Miss Shadow Lovely...
And Albert Lele.
Next up, we have...
Uh...
Melizande.
We have...
For those who don't know who Meli is...
I'm sorry if I'm pronouncing your name wrong.
Melizande.
I think one of them worked.
I'm really sorry if I pronounced it wrong.
But if you guys don't know...
She is the voice actress...
For Catalyst.
So for those in JP...
She plays Catalyst.
Yes, she's in our custom.
LOL Yeah, so...
And then...
Her teammate is Prisma.
And the assigned pro is...
I'm Madness from Furia.
That is their pro player.
That was assigned to them.
Um...
By the way, for the pro assignments...
We basically try to cater to what they requested.
So, when we gave them the captain slot...
We'd be like, which pro would you like?
Some of them requested no pros.
We were like, do you want a pro?
You don't have to have a pro.
You can just have three Vtubers.
Or choose a friend.
And we're like, that's fine.
And some choose to have a pro assigned.
And some have specific requests.
Others might not have any requests at all.
So we could get any pro we want.
Um...
So that's basically how the whole thing worked.
But yeah, that is...
Team 13.
Team 14.
We have Nia's team.
Nia Mokcha's team.
Team 14.
So, we have Nia and Annie.
And Nocturno from NRG.
Um...
Huge shoutout to Annie.
Annie was literally the person we got an hour before the stream started.
Um...
She was down to join as an emergency backup.
So, um...
Huge shoutout to Annie for wanting to join the custom and wanting to be part of it and everything.
Really great.
Um...
But yes, this is team 14.
That we have here.
Um...
Anyway...
Team 15.
We have Restia's team.
In Restia's team, we have Restia.
KSP.
And I'm really sorry, but can anybody tell me how to pronounce this name?
I was very scared of pronouncing it wrong.
Um...
Yes, Restia, the cat girl.
Hakuzen?
Hakuzen.
So it's Restia, KSP, and Hakuzen.
Um... for team 15.
Thank you guys.
I'm really happy that people here actually knows how to read compared to me.
Um... thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
Um...
But yes, we have Restia's team.
Team 16.
We have RPR.
Um... RPR with Kewpie and Tsuna from VSPO-JP.
Will be joining us.
This is RPR's team, guys.
There's not a lot of team names.
There's...
I just need you guys to know that we...
Not a lot of people gave us team names.
So...
It's just a captain's name.
You guys are saying this is gonna be a stack team.
Remember, we have nerves here.
Alright.
Team 17.
We have Sakuno's team.
So we have Sakuno, Miss Doctor, and it's Timmy.
Yes, we got Timmy here from 100 Thieves.
Yes.
Timmy's gonna be playing.
Guys, you guys should know we had so many people request Timmy.
We're sorry.
If we could split Timmy into 10 different teams, we could.
But sadly, we had to...
Sadly, we can only assign him to one team.
But yes.
We have...
It's Timmy.
I thought it was funny because apparently there's a thing where people always confuse between Sakuno and Timmy.
They think they're the same person.
So...
So that's why...
There's also...
It was requested as well.
Well, he requested Nice Wig.
And I was like, Nice Wig's fucking casting.
So I was like, I'm sorry, Sakuno.
I can't get you, Nice Wig.
But yes, anyway.
This is Sakuno's team for Team 17.
Team 18!
Yes, we have the entire 100 Thieves roster.
Guys, like me, it really is beneficial when you have your best friends with Nice Wig.
When you're besties.
But we have basically the entire 100 Thieves roster in here.
We have...
Tenjin and his friend Reruzenski.
And Designful.
That from 100 Thieves.
And they are called The Fools.
For Team 18.
Oh, last two teams, guys.
Last two teams are left.
Team 19!
We have Tsukumo's team.
Yes, we also got reps in here!
So TSM is part of this custom.
And we have...
From Neoport, we have...
Three Kohakus, by the way, I realized.
I think we have like three different Kohakus in this custom alone.
So we have Tsukumo from Neoport, Kohaku from Sony V, and we have reps from TSM.
Tsukumo requested...
It was from the forum.
They requested Hal, Timmy,
but we couldn't get Hal, and we couldn't cut up Timmy into 10 parts.
Hal was unfortunately busy on that day.
We don't want to cut up Timmy into 10 parts.
So we were like, what about reps?
And at first we were like, are you sure?
Because like, will you be okay with communicating with like an NA pro?
And they were like, we really want to play with an NA pro.
Because we were like, we could get you JP, and they were like, no, we really want an NA pro, and we're like, okay.
And I was like, how's communication?
And then they were like, the management...
Because we were talking to the manager, and then the manager was like, oh, yo, I'm a pro, why am I?
You gotta run the server, Tempo!
And yeah, they were like, we have passion.
And then I was like, you know what, that's good enough.
They really wanted an NA pro.
So, and we had reps, too.
So, we had reps on standby, we haven't assigned reps yet, and they both, they really wanted an NA professional player, so we assigned them reps, because good luck, reps.
I hope you enjoy, I hope you get to, I cannot wait for you to experience the passion.
It's actually really fun.
I love playing with passion English, because it's like, actually a really fun experience.
But yes, it's gonna be really interesting how they communicate together.
Yeah, so yeah, good luck, reps.
It'll be really fun to see.
So yes, this is team 19.
Finally!
The final team.
It will be Aoharu.
We have Kohaku, another Kohaku, by the way.
Remember I said we had three Kohakus?
Like, this is the third Kohaku.
We have Kohaku Tito from Neoport, Aoharu from Realize, and we have one Tappy, my fucking favorite pro player!
I was so happy that we got Tappy.
I was so fucking happy.
Literally, I was like, bro, we could get Tappy in here?
My day is fucking made.
From the very first time we spectated Tappy and, like, rigged the votes to get him voted as, like, MVP.
We tried to rig the votes and it would never happen.
I was so upset by that.
I don't know if you guys remembered, but one of the ALGS watchalongs, we can rig the votes to be, like, use the hashtag to tell people who your favorite who's the MVP pro is.
And then all the dragoons kept voting for Tappy.
And then we found out they don't even look at that hashtag.
That's when we found out it was fucking rigged because the entire hashtag was just us voting for Tappy.
So, I'm so happy that we managed to get Tappy in here.
Huge shoutout to Dash for getting Tappy in.
We had, like, one day to find some JP pros because the JP pros weren't able to do the scheduling.
So they had to, like, drop out, do the scheduling.
So we were like, who do we get?
And then Dash was like, wait, I know Tappy.
And I was like, fucking get him!
We have to get him!
So, I'm super happy that, you know, it feels like a circle.
We spectated Tappy in ALGS and now he's part of my custom.
So it feels like, you know, we all made it here.
But yes, that is all 20 teams for those who wanted to see, I'll just scroll past all the teams real quick for all of you guys.
So we have a lot of pros, a lot of players all around the world.
A lot of different pro players, a lot of different VTubers from different backgrounds, from different regions, different skill levels, indie, corporate.
It was very, okay, so I'll talk about this real quick while we get to the end real quick though.
While we make it to the end of this here.
Let me go back to the chatting screen real fast.
Alright, so if you're like wondering, oh, why isn't this person or why isn't that person or why isn't this VTuber in here?
Why isn't this VTuber from this company not part of the custom?
Or this VTuber from this other smaller VTuber company not in this custom?
It's very simple.
They didn't apply or ask to be invited most likely.
Because regarding like smaller companies, I did try to I did try to like allow, not allow, sorry.
That's not the right word.
Include them in and like majority of the small, like, I think I invited all the smaller VTuber companies that wanted to be a part of the custom.
To be part of it.
And why VTubers?
This is a VTuber custom.
So, and also, I wanted to make sure we balanced out NA and APAC plus the two EU players that slipped in.
Oh.
So, we try to balance, make sure that the NA players and APAC players is not like one is more NA over the other.
We try to like make sure there is a balance because it is the main reason why I'm organizing this is to celebrate the fact that LGS is in is in Japan this, or next year in 2025.
And I know I was also very lenient regarding players too.
And basically this is really really it was very hard balancing it because if somebody dropped out, I try to find a team or a person that like matches the person that couldn't play it or wasn't allowed to play it.
So like, I try to match people up to be similar just so it would be balanced.
In terms of what it is.
This is like a pilot episode and it was very, like I said anything that could happen, anything that fucked up like stuff that would mess with organizing this did happen.
So, it was very stressful.
And basically like I'm hoping, when a pilot costs $30,000 I know a lot of people are like, that's a lot of money.
The thing is, the first event is also like one of the most important events to kickstart something.
Like I might invest $30,000 on it now, but in the future maybe it will attract sponsors that want to you know, sponsor these events more and then be able to provide something similar or be able to organize these without having to use my own money and being able to provide people like a chance being able to provide people like a chance to get something out of it being able to get prizes out of it,
get memorabilia out of it Like it's an investment on something I really want to do in the future regarding planning more events similar to this.
And this doesn't mean like every event I'm going to do has a fucking insane type of prize money.
This is also because due to some players that are involved obviously it's more so of like, you know I have to establish something here and this is like me establishing like a custom that I want to try and organize and potentially do more of these in the future and being able to do more types of events similar to these in the future.
But, uh, and anyway for more VTuber-centric events, uh, this is like my first time doing like a competitive ish VTuber event but also making sure that there is a balance in between like the fun and game modes and the more like fun game modes and as well as like pew pew pew pew So,
um, it was just to, um, it's like an experiment, uh, per se.
It's definitely like an experiment on like a more competitive side because we don't get that a lot in NA as well.
If I try to organize like, um, if I try to organize it specifically in, um, NA, uh, um, it's a lot harder.
Because we don't get a lot of these like, uh, events, um, within like NA type deal.
So, this is more so of a way to experiment and see what we can do.
Yeah.
Especially if we're like, you know, like, look, I didn't say it guys.
I didn't say it.
Literally, I was screaming into our DMs being like, how the fuck do you do this?
And then Tempo was like, like, it's Apex players.
He's just like, you get used to it.
And I was just like screaming into the void being like, this is the hardest thing I've ever fucking done!
And he was like, you'll get used to it.
And I was like, I DON'T WANNA GET USED TO IT!
I've never, oh my god, I've never been so frustrated before organizing an event.
Like, the amount of things I went through the last two weeks, I was screaming at it.
But yes, it is a...
Um, this is basically, this is a trial run of sorts.
And, you know, like I said, there is, like, uh...
Uh...
I am very excited to be able to do something like this.
I hope to be able to do something more like this in the future, but also like, maybe not be fully in charge of this in the future and maybe get management to help me out.
Because my management team was like, are you fucking stupid?
And I was like, yes, um...
My management team was like, yeah, maybe don't.
Like, cause I was like, you know, screaming into the void, as in the void was tempo.
And then I started screaming at management being like, why do I have to find a team within 24 hours?!
And I'm like, oh my god!
And I was like, I have to find another person?!
And then, my management was like, if you do something like that again, um...
Maybe like, you should let us handle this, we should let us...
Hahahaha...
Anyway, also I wanna say, um, we do, I'll show you one of our emergency backup subs, because um, she can, she can speak both Japanese and So if something happens, we have someone that covers both languages that we need the most right now.
So, we have Eileen.
For those who don't know her, she is a very talented VTuber.
She speaks a lot of languages.
And her name is Eileen Noir.
And she is our emergency backup that can speak English and Japanese.
So, if anything happens in any team, we have Eileen here.
This is one of our emergency subs.
She's gonna be an emergency sub for a team that was gonna be an emergency sub for a different team, but then we got a person.
So then I was like, if anything happens, are you free on the 30th to be there?
And she said, yeah.
So, she's one of our three emergency backup subs in case something happens.
Now I have backups because I don't know what's gonna happen anymore.
I don't know what's gonna happen.
I can't take chances anymore.
The thing is, I never had an issue where I had to find so many backups.
But I don't trust myself anymore.
I don't trust myself anymore.
So, I'm so thankful for Eileen for being there to help us.
Yeah, I figured out that backups is a really good idea because we still have the 30th.
We have 60 players.
Something might happen.
60 players!
Probability-wise, I don't know.
Doesn't seem quite well for me.
So, what I learned so far is that it's very stressful.
Like I said, I've never organized something as stressful as this before.
So, I'm hoping that this goes well.
We'll see you guys next week to see if it does go well.
Anyway, guys!
That's the custom!
The Doki Bird X Oversight Custom 2024!
We hope you enjoy this announcement and I'll see you next week for the actual event.
Like I said, you're wondering why isn't this person, why isn't that person.
Usually, like I said, it's a balance.
It was basically, there's people that I personally invited, people that applied on the forum, people that messaged me to get invited.
And that's basically it.
So, it was a balance of all three of these.
And I wanted to have a lot of different skill levels participating.
And like I said, usually when I look for personal invites, these are the things I look at.
I look at, have they played Apex before on stream?
Do they follow me?
So I can message them.
Very important, by the way!
Annie was one of those I messaged because she follows me and she used to play Apex.
So I was like, do you want to be a, we need somebody right now.
And she was like, yeah!
So it was very easy!
Because mostly for me, it was like, am I able to message them if I want to invite somebody?
Because usually for DMs, a lot of YouTubers close their DMs.
And like the only, including me, but like, well, I do have like, there's one way to contact me.
You just have to have Twitter blue.
But like, even then I don't see those DMs unless like I follow you or like unless like, yeah, unless I follow you, then it shows up there.
But if you have Twitter blue and you try to DM me, because I get a lot of DMs.
I had to turn on Twitter blue.
It's more so of like, it goes to the thing where like, I don't know, the other category where, where it's like, you don't know who's actually DMing you, but you can check it type deal.
So there's that.
So the easiest way is that and sometimes, you know, you have to, they have the option where they follow this person so you can DM them.
Basically, yeah, the pending requests, that type of shit.
But yeah, that's basically it.
Those are basically what I looked at for like personal invites.
Do they follow me?
So I can send them a DM and ask them if they want to join or and like, have they played Apex before?
And that's really it for like personal invites.
Then I had people that asked me to be or do I have them on Discord or is there a way to contact them on Discord?
Also that too, the Discord option, which sometimes they, you know, if I already have them on Discord on server, like if I share server with them, fucking easy.
And then I had lots of people that asked me to be invited to be part of the custom, like Gerard asked if he could be part of the custom and I was like, sure, fucking let's go!
Like RPR asked if he could be in the custom, fucking come in!
Stuff like that.
So we had people asking and then I looked at the forums.
We had around, I believe, like Neoport actually applied via the forums.
I was very surprised to see a member from Neoport wanting to join in.
And I saw Neoport in there and I was like, yeah, of course!
Yeah, it would be a great honor to have JP.org to be part of it.
So Neoport applied via the forum and I was like, join in!
Project Kawaii applied via the forum, fucking let's go!
Akka Virtual applied via the forum, come right in!
Majority of people from companies that applied via the forum, I let them in.
It's that easy.
That's really it.
Anyway guys, that's it.
That's all to say.
Hope you enjoy this announcement for this custom.
Hope it goes okay.
We'll see next week.
We'll see!
I don't know, anything can happen.
From this custom, organizing it alone, yeah, anything can fucking happen.
Anyway, here's our hashtag for the event.
We'll see what happens.
Main broadcast, casting-wise, will be on Wig's channel.
On my channel, we'll have the interviews still on my channel.
I mean, Wig's gonna be streaming it as well, so you'll be able to hear that too.
But if you wanna watch it on YouTube, I'll have the interviews, I'll talk about the rules, we'll talk about the winners per game, we'll talk about the rules and everything.
So, like, explanations of everything will be on my channel, where we explain everything.
I will be starting earlier than the custom, so I can talk to Wig in Greek before the custom starts.
That's it.
Anyway guys, thank you all for coming.
Thank you to every- oh shit, forgot to say, credits-wise.
Credits!
I'm sorry, I didn't have time to finish the credits scene.
But we have me!
Hello, it's me.
I'll post the actual finished credits on Twitter, because I didn't finish the graphics for it.
No, it's stupid, because the graphics designer was like, are you sure you can do all of this?
You can give me the information, and then I'll just put everything in.
And I was like, don't worry, I got this.
But obviously, I don't have my shit together right now.
So, that's one of the things I forgot to do.
I'm so- I'm so sorry, that's one of the things I forgot.
I'm really sorry.
Anyway, I'm sorry, there's like empty space, because I forgot to put the graphics in there.
But I want you to know who fucking made the graphics.
So, Sugartype made the graphics.
Gamersubs will be handling the medals and the memorabilia.
Oversight is our partnership who helped us with the pros.
Um, Caster!
Nice wig and greek!
I could do it live!
If you really- Guys, don't make me do it live, because I will.
I- Nice wig, greek.
There we go.
Anyway, casters, we have nice wig and greek.
And then for our live translator, we have Dash.
There we go.
We'll just be like, here.
Dash, okay.
Um, he has no face.
That's just him.
Dash, there we go.
Um, that's basically it.
This was basically a team of me, Dash, and Tempo, slash Oversight.
Tempo works on Oversight.
And Sugartype for the logo and the graphics.
Huge shoutout to Sugartype for creating all the graphics for us.
Um, but yes, me, Dash, and Tempo.
We managed to fucking put all of this together.
Us three.
Nobody else.
Just literally us just fucking hammer and nail and some superglue and hope everything will work out.
So, yes, huge shoutout.
And potential sponsor negotiation.
We're negotiating potential sponsor.
We'll announce it later this week when it happens.
But yes, thank you everybody.
Anyway, we're gonna call it here.
Thank you everybody for coming to the announcement.
Um, we'll see you, uh, we'll see you next week.
Um, this is a pilot, guys.
It feels like a pilot.
It really does feel like a pilot episode.
Nothing is ironed out yet.
And yes, as always everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!